it was a sight full of wonder and war
the vast swells of the omnipotency
the surging hollow war they made
as they rolled along the eight gunnels
like gigantic bowls
in a boundless bowling green
early 70s there was
there were 30 35 scrim changes here on
nantucket
they're all gone now
scrimshaw is a traditional american art
form it's actually the only
art form that was indigenous to the us
it started with the yankee whalers back
in the 18th and 19th century
you've got 29 or 30 guys sitting on a
on a ship with a lot of as i said
downtime
somebody got the idea to scratch away on
this
canvas which was the tooth there are log
books where they say all hands are busy
scrimshanting
that i've had for almost half a century
remember fran howard oh yeah seven seas
when they say five to twenty bucks
and uh you know she used to sell them by
size and they have a great they got the
old prices on them yeah yeah and a great
age
there's a tooth here
he bought that from the late charlie
sale who was a famous
scrimshander he passed away 25 years ago
and i bought all his teeth
to be working on one of their teeth is
an honor
and they are valuable things because you
know
what it took to
get this tooth
they have a story
you know that whale had a story i wish i
knew it but
you can make up your own story
death to the living
born with the killers
to sailors wives
and greasy luck to whalers
you